the one can also feel the vibe yeah that  they have this this energy going around  them that they want to achieve something  big  very dangerous team for sure  absolutely yeah  um so let's take a look at those  positions in the france match uh yeah  radicals i mean if radic doesn't win  this i will be very very surprised it's  just a position that  like it's just impossible to improve for  black even if nothing you know wins by  force there's just no way the pawns on  b6 and b5 ever get traded  and also every single piece white has is  better than  its black counterpart like the rook is  more active the knight is more active  the king is more active and you're also  up upon  so yeah radix should win which means  that everything uh everything depends on  that game between uh uh lagaard and  uh wojciech  and uh  yeah we are also getting the update that  yeah polyglass designed in this hopeless  position so yeah hey guys he has